you know guys i've run into a lot of
french people over here in europe
a lot of french people and guess what
they've been lovely
every single person has been lovely
just making me eat a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
sandwich
so robbie running into nice french
people yes yeah i'm here in um in london
and man am i am i being made to eat my
words
uh no no no none of them listen to the
podcast so i wasn't taking any any [ __ ]
from anybody it's just that uh everybody
is everybody with a french accent seems
to be very nice
but you know i'm not in france putting
your words on a nice baguette
but i'm wondering if these are the
french people that left france because
they couldn't stand the people in france
i'm just i don't know i'll have to go to
france again to to find out but the
first time i was not met with a lot of
um welcome how old were you the first
time you were in france 24
or something like that and i was really
24 year old takes it more personally i
think the 24 year old is like you know a
grown man it's like you're coming at me
with some [ __ ] all right bring it yeah
that's fair that's fair well anyway the
the french here have been wonderful as
ha as are the english and
uh it's really just a a wonderful
melting pot this city i love it i love
it in london
i've only been
twice and but both times i was like
doing press stuff so you go into like a
hotel room and you you know
they bring in like a hundred people and
you just answer the same question over
and over again oh
no i've never had a horrible boss and
i think i did it for pacific rim too and
it was it was uh fun and exciting to be
in london but i wish i'd seen more of
the city when i was there well i went to
i went to a i did a football game at
wembley stadium and i can tell you that
was an incredible experience and it was
really fun up until the game
part um
which was less fun
but
um
your buddy jason sedakis came
um oh how's he doing he's great he's
here shooting that other show on apple t
t lizzo t lezzo tdsu
will ferrell came he was very sweet and
david beckham david beckham was there
and he was did you say will ferrell
farrell was there
[Music]
and he's he's exactly who you would want
him to be when you meet him i know at
least my experience has been that that's
just that's right lovely and uh funny
you know who else was lovely was david
beckham
and i kind of thought he might be just
based on some documentary footage that
i've seen of him and interviews and
whatnot but you never really know until
you're talking to him
that's a real nice guy
nice people over in england yeah we've
uh we've done a 180 on the french
well we're here to talk about glenn
because he's not here um
we're here but that's what we're really
going to talk about like uh it's messing
up our episode yeah it's messing up our
flow yeah somehow megan who's apparently
in the middle of
between
mars and
and earth um
considering her internet but she was
still able to to sign in
and charlie you're you're it's like 5 45
oh six o'clock in the morning where you
are yeah i was up at 5 15. um
my wife has the covet and uh so does uh
anyone who could possibly help with her
kid but i'm up before everybody so i'm
hoping to jam this out and then i you
know got to make school lunches and
or a single school lunch and uh you know
jump into all that so but we so so you
made the podcast
and glenn
that's my dedication to the fans
you know which which who put us here
yes um i can't just turn my back on them
i feel the same i mean i could watch
this
speaking with a low volume is that
because you don't want to wake up i'm
terrified of waking anyone up in this
house and then being like well it's on
me it's on me to uh
um but but the great thing about my son
is that
he won't get out of bed because he knows
it's a school day
you know if it's
like a full-on teenager like like a
weekend he would
he would you know he'll be up already
but uh on a school day it's like i gotta
drag him out of bed
god bless i get it i get it was that how
you were charlie when you were growing
up
i i certainly didn't love going to
school you know um
i probably got out of bed maybe a little
bit easier but no i hated going to
school i mean it was cold you had to go
outside it's like freezing staying out
there waiting for the bus your your hair
would freeze if it was wet
um
then you got to lug your trombone on the
bus
right you got to get your trombone you
got to sit in the front seat because you
got you know the [ __ ] bus driver
doesn't want you carrying that thing up
and down the aisles banging up banging
up her bus
everyone's fighting and throwing gum and
which that up that i like that was
exciting to watch you know i wasn't
really getting in the melee but i liked
when one broke out
but um no no didn't uh i mean i love
seeing my friends but the whole school
work part no no no no no no if i could
take a pill and know everything i need
to know i would have done it
everyone would yeah i don't think
anybody really remembers enjoying school
my children came here
uh to to watch the game and then they
just flew back today and they were real
bummed but mostly they're bummed about
having to go to school
tomorrow which is gonna be tough yeah
but you know what get over it
kids
i didn't go to europe for the first time
until i was 25 like i just said i had to
pay for my goddamn self kids
get up and go to work go to school suck
it up
these
are so ungrateful
speaking of ungrateful because glenn's
not here
um
we're gonna need to
we're gonna do a best of the podcast
which i think is is brilliant to do a
best of
only how many episodes have we done meg
30 something 33. we've done 33 episodes
of this podcast you know who you know
who was number 33 charlie
no larry bird
and larry bird was number 33 and he and
and his first season he he won
i believe he won rookie of the year his
his his first season and and i believe
that you could have show showed a a a
string of highlights from his first
season
33 games into the season and it would
have been very very impressive and i
think that's what we're going to do here
they grow them different in french lick
indiana that's right indiana can't stop
talking about french what a name
yeah french lick
french india who's coming up with that
how they come up with that name it's
like
well i like the word french
but what if we added a lick to it well
what what if like what if it's somebody
that came back and they're like the
french suck
they suck but we can't we can't call it
town let's call this town french suck
and someone else was like nah they'll be
on to us what if we keep it like
you know what else they do they lick but
what you know you know like like what if
like you know you know what it's like
you're at a restaurant and a frenchman
just walks up just kind of like licks
back your neck and says okay now what
what would you like to eat
uh
yeah you know he walked up on you he
says uh hello monsieur and then he come
on licking up on your neck and let's
call freshnet
you gotta have like a louisiana bayou
there thing at the end
yeah i don't know i went through like
nine accidents
i enjoyed it
i enjoyed it well yeah so we're gonna do
we're gonna do a best of episode of the
podcast here where we're going to find
highlights from all of your favorite
moments from the last 33 episodes
it's so easy
can we break and it's sort of like jesus
not a cross look all right now we're
doing mcelhenny's wingspan
mr spielberg stephen stephen
drinking water
i'm feeling a lot of love okay
and then uh when we come back we're
gonna be talking about the gang gets
whacked
part one and part two which i can't wait
to talk about but first let's talk about
the things we've already talked about
[Music]
which beetle would you do you think you
are then
definitely paul
yeah
okay well who which which kink are you
jerry garcia yeah see there oh yeah
let's see that's the problem with the
kinks
yeah
yes
do you think i am
i think you're a little bit of paul i
think you're paul too i think you're
paul
if you guys call me ringo i swear to
[ __ ] i swear to god i think we oh
george harrison you know jordan
maybe john i mean you're definitely
harrison like you know like uh
yeah yeah
john lennon
he was about to give me john lennon well
in terms of the relationships
you could go and write an amazing song
on your own and then you don't get the
credit for that but then you're like you
can do it man but you see like paul is
like a maniac like constantly like
pushing things forward and saying guys
like let's go let's go let's go
that's me but i feel like that's you too
yeah it is that's true
yeah i don't know okay so we're we're
all a little bit of paul mccartney yeah
a little bit of john lennon
george harrison yeah and nobody's ringo
ringo's finger was [ __ ] great by the
way yeah we're all three ego maniacs
right you think we're that we're the
beatles
wow so you guys have uh both have
kicking indoors stories i don't i don't
have any kicking indoors probably good
that's another kick in the door it
always sounded fun to me though it's one
of those things like god that that
sounds you know there's like a handful
of things that always sounded kind of
interesting to me that i always wanted
to test the theory of like when i was a
kid i was always like get like kicking a
door down like what how do i do this why
don't we in our new studio we just
commit to whatever the cost is to repair
a door okay
and then we just give you your dream
buddy this is hollywood
you know like you can do whatever you
want all right let's keep indoors let's
do it let's get let's get to work here
[Music]
my angles guys check my ankles make sure
we got i've got a camera inside as well
to get the inside cover
oh okay you got a wide there so you're
going to kick it in but what's the story
like take us through because like let's
take us tickets to a place all right how
are you feeling right now
uh i'm excited it's a little close
okay oh same you did it again
um i'm feeling i'm feeling good um i'm
not that warmed up i do want to say
tell it to the folks at home yeah uh
folks i i do want to make this very
clear um that i never uh took martial
arts in my entire life what really yep
so that
[Laughter]
so what you're about to see is happening
in real time so you're not even a ninja
anything you think you're gonna be able
to kick the story uh ninjas don't kick
indoors for the record they sneak in
windows they're sneakier than that
they're much sneakier than that okay
this is more of a sort of a swat team
type situation yes i like that okay and
can i ask a question
is it more fun if it's glenn kicking in
the door or do you want to play one of
those characters from the 80s meaning
you have a story and there's somebody or
something in that door that you need to
get to because you want to say something
cool after you kick it in you want to
come into the door into your camera in
there and announce something that's true
who are you looking for where's the girl
live your dream here for like um what
yeah what's the what's the what's the
narrative you know where's the girl
something like that that could that
could be the villain or the hero i don't
know how do you get your kicks
oh you want it to be like a one-liner
okay oh yeah yeah yeah okay
let's go
it's just a great one boom let's go
because well i think also like commit to
it right so if it doesn't work once
don't stop like keep going until it
opens and you might if you wind up
putting a hole like through the door
you might have to bash through it like
the uh the the high c guy
through the high guy yeah yeah yeah
the kool-aid guy sorry
oh yeah yeah that's what you should say
okay oh yeah oh yeah okay i'm sorry i
had something else all right ready
everybody
yeah here we go glenn's lined up he's
lined up
okay
okay here we go
but yeah come check this out uh
i mean let's grab the camera here you
went straight into the drywall
so let me
get a little shot here
into the drywall we've made our stuff to
fix a hole so
how do you feel right now glenn how do
you feel uh an exhilaration that i
haven't felt uh in in quite some time uh
exhilaration haven't felt in quite some
time
mike was too close yeah okay
how does your foot feel
it's fine
what is good what else can we break can
you tell me what's in that coffee is it
just coffee is it what kind of special
is there like an egg cracked in there do
you have hot pepper is it
brewed in
why why do you ask that because i know
you always have
pepper and an egg
is that is that a crazy thing to ask now
hold on a second there was a moment it's
not
this [ __ ] was drinking coffee
that also had egg in it no
what coffee and eggs hold on a second
what was the point what was the best
coffee what was the bullet coffee that's
butter it's like a bunch of spring it's
a butter okay well grandfather uh bullet
coffee uh which is otherwise known as an
actually known as bulletproof coffee
uh is uh
is coffee and butter and mct oil uh and
sometimes coconut oil there's different
ways to make it but the main thing that
bulletproof coffee is by the way that's
not pepper okay that might sound strange
but like by the way i never really i did
the bulletproof coffee thing for like
five seconds just absolutely right
destroyed my stomach yes i'm not i hate
it
the reason i was asking was because it's
not that crazy to assume that to go from
butter to an egg i don't know no you
know what i i have uh coffee with my
eggs all the time and i've never thought
to like stir the eggs straight into the
coffee
i could be missing out i mean that's a
very
get some eggs have a cup of coffee
that's that's i'm down to try it i'm
down to try to like you know
coffee or coffee egg oh i bet how about
how about this how about this like you
do
some cold coffee right cold brew coffee
put it in a blender with some ice
um a couple of crack a couple eggs in
there maybe put some butter in there
right
and a little bit of honey maybe to sweet
well no you can't do that the egg coffee
would be good for you a coffee egg would
be a coffee that's been hard-boiled an
egg that's been hard-boiled in a pot of
coffee that would be it that would be a
god that would be a coffee egg but i
would chop a coffee
yeah like in a percolator right where
you're actually boiling let's make both
of those and then see which ones there's
that's something that a tea i think is a
thing but wait wait no it's getting tea
but the the coffee's not gonna penetrate
the shell of the egg and actually affect
the flavor so yes it
of this is
so i mean you were so clear i'm so sure
that that oh
yes it will it most
certainly will you know it's like you
work
how is it gonna penetrate the shell of
the egg by the way i love your passion
for this i really do i have no idea
there really is i have no idea
because i i've had a tea egg before i've
had a tea egg which was an egg that was
kidding boiled in tea and it was
delicious it tasted like tea yeah
very good i hear blowing my mind i've
never heard of that a tea egg yes what
is this it's a it's from other cultures
what culture japan
oh
and chinese chinese okay i don't really
i don't know chinese tea eggs yes
chinese tea eggs and then mine do they
will you find it in a savory liquid with
star anise well that's why you eat
sticks and peppercorns
star and uh do they peel the egg before
they boil it
that's what we need to know you can't
peel it
before you boil
if you peel an egg before you go
what are they saying do they do they
boil it and then like soak it in the tea
or something like after all right crack
it open crack open the boiled egg and
soak it we should have charlie kelly
trying to peel and unboil yeah
he can't figure it out he's frustrated
yeah he wants to make yeah okay all
right coffee egg oh yeah
i'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
that that's gonna be gross
yeah i'm with you i think that's gonna
be unpleasant
i have something to leave you guys even
though i'm not dead but i have a special
treat for you today you do which is i
this morning
i hard-boiled these eggs in coffee no
[ __ ] way oh no to see whether uh it
would get through so if you guys want to
peel these eggs and then taste them yeah
let's do it
let's do it you didn't peel it before
you boiled it i did not peel okay so you
just you just boiled
you just i made a pot of coffee and then
i put the eggs into the coffee with no
extra water just the coffee
and then i boiled them as i standardly
do hard-boiled eggs
do you have salt there's no yeah there's
no brown coloration in here though like
with the tea what do you say the tea the
shells are still smelling
a billion pieces um i'm not good at this
i would say that i think maybe let's
look up how the tea egg is cooked but i
think
what i meant to say
i did uh look that up and actually they
soak it in tea after they hard boiled
after they boil it so oh
so so this is going to be nothing it's
probably not going to taste like coffee
this is going to taste like it smells
like an egg
it just tastes like an egg yeah oh does
it so yeah well
so we got to do it the way they do the
tea you gotta soak it in coffee you
gotta and this is what i meant
when i said do you peel it first you
gotta boil it peel it
and then soak it in some coffee and soak
it but definitely boil it first before
you peel it hmm well megan thank you
very much
my husband was like what are you doing
and i was like i'm working i'm working
here hey guys wait wait for those freaks
out there let's do a little asmr
why um
stop
stop oh my god
that doesn't bother me that doesn't
bother you wait let me let me do it let
me see if i can it won't bother me if
you're doing it on purpose
really
right that's what we established chewing
sounds don't bother it's not the sound
it's not it's that it's that people
don't give a [ __ ] yes it's the it's the
chaos
the first question is what makes glenn
the most angry
[Laughter]
just in general
yeah
oh
okay oh wow i got it
charlie's ready to rock
you see that's amazing how there's so
much
that there's so much but
you went for you just went for one
charlie show us your answer
okay i wrote
uh chewing loud oh
yeah okay chewing gum and chewing
chewing loud
chewers you know smacky foods the
difficult thing i think about this is
that so many things make me angry so i
wrote down
uh
a sort of a broader category which would
encompass what you wrote charlie can i
have a one second guess i won't write it
but just just to say yes did you write
the word life
wait i think i know what you did i think
i know what you did i think i know what
you did yeah go for it you wrote you
wrote peep is having to do with people
not giving a [ __ ]
there's an injustice of your people big
one
you are you you didn't say it the way i
said it but i think what you're saying
is what i is i think what you mean is
what i meant when i wrote what i wrote
yeah what'd you write
lack of awareness
so this bothers you
yes it does
you know what i'm doing on purpose yeah
so trying bob there's a lot of people
out there right now that are [ __ ]
really grossed out and then there's some
people that are getting erections right
right right
right
yeah i guess you know i don't know is
that what it is it's like are women into
this mega they're getting turned on it's
only man
yes i do meg speaks for a woman
it's a good egg meg thank you yeah
that's a good egg that's good coffee and
these drinks turns out you can boil your
egg and coffee or water and it won't
penetrate the shell boil it and whatever
whatever you're already boiling just go
ahead and throw an egg in there
it won't make a
difference that's basically what we're
saying well guys this has been great
brought to you by egg
egg
it's just fine for your trying
[Music]
times guys we know
it's your favorite part of the podcast
where we hawk products to pay megan's
rent
rob what is going on with with megan's
rentals i'll tell you what's going on
this week she spent a little too much
money on champagne in the uk and now she
can't afford her rent
sounds like champagne problems to me
right well yeah you you should have put
together more of a travel fund there meg
fortunately we've got you covered with
our partners at viori
the most comfortable exercise and lounge
apparel this side of the gym or the
couch
yeah okay so what you're talking about
here is called athleisure it's the art
of looking like you're working out even
when you're not which is extremely
important for fooling people that you're
more physically active than you are
and vyori is definitely the brand to do
that because not only do they look great
they are full on more comfortable than
whatever you're lounging around in right
now i mean more comfort who didn't want
that let's just say you actually did
work out
good for you stop bragging about it
whatever yeah well rob you'd be in luck
there too because you can run in your
vyori core shorts you can train in them
you can do yoga you can even swim you
can swim in these shorts okay so when
there's a there's a good chance that my
day will involve both water and air
and i need transition shorts
this is the first pair i reach for and
viori is offsetting 100
of both their carbon and plastic
footprint did you hear that
no footprints zero footprints
zero footprints i like that it's like an
eagle that never stops soaring high
above the ground that's for yours okay
so look vyori is an investment in your
happiness for our listeners they are
offering 20
off your first purchase get yourself
some of the most comfortable and
versatile clothing on the planet at
viori.com
sunny pod that's v u o r i dot com slash
sunny pod not only will you receive 20
off your first purchase but enjoy free
shipping
on any u.s orders over 75 dollars and
free returns go to viori.com
sunnypod and discover the versatility of
viori
[Music]
he feels that when if he sees jaws where
he's like ah this doesn't
just doesn't retract me good though yeah
but he doesn't he probably see he just
sees all he's probably got some clunky
scenes that he looks at and is like i
wouldn't stage that one that way anymore
or something what's that spielberg do
you still mr spielberg stephen stephen
how do you feel about
the first
jaws movie
i think it's pretty good
i mean i still like it i mean i mean you
know
i don't love everything about it but
there's some things that i think still
work and i i do regret that the shark
didn't look better because i still think
the movie would have been better if the
shark
if we'd been able to see the track more
but that turned out to be a good thing
according to some people i don't know
i stand by it i stand by it
i don't know is that a bad steven
spielberg what do you talk well let's
ask steven steven how is your impression
of yourself is it good or is it bad i
don't think i sound like that
well
thanks for coming by steven spielberg
thank you thank you that was yeah steven
spielberg wow good would it get
[Music]
when i was a kid we would go to the
beach and and there was no sunblock my
mother used to spray us with vinegar
yeah to get to to get you dark yeah well
it was to keep away the flowers
yeah that is the funniest thing
picturing these are what mcelhenny kids
just reeking in vinegar imagining like
you coming over to a kid like hey you
guys want to play a frisbee or something
like oh god
smell my eyes are watering trying to
talk to the skin [ __ ] man how much fish
and chips did you have what the [ __ ] are
you like this guy smells like a [ __ ]
salad
crazy crazy even worse than that the
second you go in the water that vinegar
is off yeah but when you came out she
had more of it she just
she's
now i ask her like why why was i sprayed
down with vinegar it's and i'm like do
you think that they'd help to like
engage the sun in some way and she was
like uh it's um by the way it's it's
still unclear a hundred percent she's
like honey i was loaded up yeah yeah she
was
100
no doubt we would go down there with her
and her sisters and her friends
because in jersey they had these like
horse flies that would bite you
it was like
they don't like the vinegar so it keeps
the flies away from you and then but no
no no my kids covered in vinegar
she also loved for some reason
she loved the look of those like of like
those like swimmer like like in the
european oh no like they look like
underwear but those aren't okay yes yes
like a swimmer like a swimmer she loved
that look right and we were too young
but i was old enough i was probably like
nine or it wasn't either nine or ten and
she was like you just look so cute in
these and meanwhile like
you know hey maybe at like six you don't
care but by the time you hit like 10
you're like my dick is tiny
and it looks so bad yeah it looks so
much smaller yeah like yeah and so now
i'm where i'm going
god only knows how it's reacting to the
vinegar too yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah like a balsamic
[Laughter]
i did remember caring once like 10 or
11.
i remember there being like a group of
kids and me always like having my hands
over my dick and then like my cousin
being like look man there's no hiding
there's no hiding you got to get a new
suit you guys just got to get a new suit
and i was like all right
so 11 years old you were still wearing
like the european uh maybe ten yeah like
i'll get some i'll get some photos
because we have some photos i look happy
in the photos i do really enjoy when i
see uh it's always like an older
gentleman it's always a man like you
know well into his 60s or above
you know and those guys are just like i
don't give a [ __ ] this is what i like
yeah this is what i want to wear this is
what i like this is what makes me
comfortable and i don't care how it
makes you feel
well i'll tell you what i was tan as
[ __ ] like for as as as irish skin that i
have i was like because we would be out
there on the beach every day covered in
vinegar with no clothing with no
clothing on so i was so tan the photos
you see of me i'm like this is crazy i
look so
so dark how does the vinegar affect the
sun does it does it make you get more
sun or does it actually block this i
think she from her
point of view i think it did have no no
it didn't block the sun i think it was
like an or it would have the same
properties as like a baby oil that's
what i'm saying so it enhanced the i
believe so yeah like she wanted us tan
yeah right not it just because that was
the healthy look
you know right right i want my baby i
want my kids to look healthy yeah i'm
gonna spray him and vinegar get him out
yeah i want this kid and if he's covered
in horse fly bumps then that negates the
whole thing sure yeah i'll be going to
resemble a french fry
you know like
my dick didn't look great when i was i
was a little kid i don't know if you
should be looking a little kid's dick
anyway but like i think my my body
looked all right
yeah i guess so um what percentage of
people are going to try the vinegar
thing now they're like oh you're really
tan let me try the vinegar listen i grew
up in alabama where we had a shitload of
horse flies and nobody ever sprayed me
in vinegar nobody ever suggested
spraying you know me down it could have
been to [ __ ] with us i don't know it
could have been to be like look we got
to toughen this kid up right so we got
to get him out there and like having
kids pick at him so he can
i don't know get though so he can spend
the rest of his life overcompensating
yes it's a bizarre move one way or the
other yeah yes just to spray yourself in
vinegar is very strange yeah you should
have i wish to have my mom on the
podcast and
have her answer forever i feel like i
don't remember anything oh i don't know
you're supposed to get vinegar all over
you on it that's what you do
stop robbie you loved it but as you age
it definitely gets harder you have oh
for sure for men you have less
testosterone you
your skin looks so you're never going to
look the same as you would in your 20s
even if you got into the same kind of
shape
our skin's all stretched out and [ __ ]
i'm getting things hacked off my body
every other week from sun damage from
the vinegar
yeah yeah i got a big thing on my face i
got to get cut out my face on my face i
don't see it yeah you can't you can't
see it you'll see it when there's a
giant scar there oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
i mean look cool are you wearing makeup
right now why can't i see this thing on
your face what's wrong with your face
[ __ ] are you talking i've already had
you know have you had things removed
from your body yeah okay so they remove
it then they biopsy it yeah
and so this one i got a biopsy and it's
like some kind of there is nothing on
your face
anybody see it because they cut it you
might need to switch dermatologists
because this guy might be making a
killing off you just be like here's a
rich guy i'm just going to keep chopping
[ __ ] off him and then yeah i'm going to
chop this guy up wow you might drop him
a bit you know what i mean because uh
i i went to a guy
uh this is years ago and got some like i
had a freckle on my back and i have a
big scar now from they cut it off and
like 12 stitches whatever and then i go
to a different guy now and it's like
he's never
barely cutting off anything
you know i mean i feel like the other
guy was just knife happy well maybe
maybe the first maybe the first one was
a good doctor and this one's killing you
well no not judging by the office the
second guy's got a better better looking
office if you do wonder how those
doctors get into certain specialties
right you go to med school because very
you know very few people when they're
you know six years old and all the other
kids are like i want to be an astronaut
i want to be a football player and he's
like i want to shave people's you know
parts of their skin off and biopsy them
nobody does that so they i want to look
at their moles i want to look at moles i
want to stick my finger up a guy's butt
all day long
yeah nobody's dream is that when they're
a kid
i'm talking about problem
doctor
i'm not demanding that he wants to be a
doctor i didn't say that [ __ ] would want
to be i didn't say that he said no kids
want to be adopted dreams of being a
proctologist
yeah you're trying to listen to the
specificity of what i'm saying i'm not a
proctologist where i was about about
mole what i was about to say was
was a kid does grow up though thinking i
want to be a doctor and then eventually
that turns into i don't know
you know some and some people do just
become internists or general
practitioners and you know whatever but
then you know somewhere along the way
somebody's got to go
well i guess i'll be the butt guy you
know what i mean i guess i'll check out
butthole
but like are you already into that [ __ ]
like are you going through med school
and you're like discovering that you're
like i i'm kind of fascinated by like
what's inside people's butts you know
yeah i want to see the blood itself then
i want to go through the butt and see
everything i want to see the journey
from the butthole through the intestines
you know what i mean maybe you're
looking at it and saying like so many
men die of
prostate cancer so you're just seeing
dollar signs no you're thinking that you
want to save
maybe it's a documentary there's a lot
of money
there's a lot of money in saving lives
not a lot of people want to do it
and i do
[Applause]
i don't want my drink to be my meal i
would drink every single meal if i could
really everything you don't really want
to be chewing and
chewing is a
massive waste of time and energy
you want to mix it with my saliva and
swallow it that's it that's it well the
way you chew it is a waste of time
though
i do chew on it
there's a lot of chewing there's
compartmentalizing
it sits there for a while or something
else is chewed and moved up into the top
of your mouth then at some point
factory
you're separating the egg from the salt
in your mouth somehow
because you've learned what will
metabolize faster so right now you are
turning food
[Music]
welcome to the always sunny podcast
you're on with rob charlie and glenn hey
what's going on over there
yes hi megan oh hi
the megan fan all right all right you
spoke directly to megan who are we
speaking with today
so do we
first of all who are we speaking with
today
i'm daniella
are you on the [ __ ] wow okay cool are
you actually taking a shot are you
taking a [ __ ] or are you peeing
no i'm taking a [ __ ] this is nice this
is amazing that is amazing is it a good
one have you been are you hydrated or is
it is it coming out runny is it and is
it a mess
a thousand times or is nothing going to
come out is it going okay or how are you
it's one of those where you like sit
down and then you kind of like get bored
and you're just like there and then i
called in and i was like
well if you need to stop to push your
grunt that's fine yeah it's all well
i'm sorry and i i missed the first part
has any has any been um exported yet
just like little little little little
dots
but you're looking at nuggets but you're
looking for a bunch right she's getting
she's getting milked
out she's getting milk duds and she
wants fall snickers bars i'm sensing a
hydration problem here yeah yeah i'm
going to suggest that most
mornings this morning i got to warm up
all right all right okay this is the
first one you hurt yourself she's
popping the cork sometimes this happens
right the first [ __ ] of the day i think
y'all really she had a question for me
got scared now why is it a morning uh
poop for you where are you calling us
from yeah are you in hawaii i'm from i'm
i'm calling from arizona okay okay 10 30
so it's not it's kind of not late that's
a young person's morning you know what i
mean like
we're old we're up at seven with the
kids yeah what's your question for megan
because megan megan deserves a question
you can ask her anything and she will
tell you
okay uh megan um
have you done your bowel movement for
the day
this is amazing this is a while uh
yeah yeah i don't bring anything into
this room other than enthusiasm for
these guys that's right yeah yeah yeah
you can't have poop in your body and do
a podcast
yeah we know we know we know
i have a follow-up question megan which
podcast did you call into while you were
uh
yeah who do you usually call it yeah i i
don't know i keep it to myself okay yeah
yeah that's fair okay well listen we
hope that you can get a nice full
snickers bar worth of poop out yeah we
hope you have a full evacuation you know
what i mean a complete elimination yeah
thank you guys you all made my day y'all
like and then it's just started this was
fantastic
all right well enjoy your bowel movement
and thanks for calling the sunny podcast
thank you
[Music]
there's a guest actor in this episode
and i don't want to name the person
because
this the story i'm going to tell is sort
of a personal story
uh but it he it was this actor's first
ever audition for anything oh yeah glenn
do you remember this story he he he
would be happy to tell the story i
believe it might be worth oh getting in
touch with this leah's friend
uh rob you say his name and then uh and
then we can
beep it out or whatever and then and
then if we get permission from him we'll
put it in okay his name
so
megan you don't know this story right so
i guess we'll tell it to you in the
listener yes so now and then maybe you
tell the story and then we'll have to
call in and tell
his version of it that maybe we might
miss because this is now okay ten years
ago but it is amazing right right right
he was very cavalier with yesterday yeah
so we had met him
i guess after season one or two and uh
well he's friends with our makeup artist
leah voltron and he said that he had his
first ever audition for a movie
television anything
and it was for our show and um he went
our casting director at the time was a
guy named john pepsidera when we started
the show and he goes to john pepsidera's
office and he's as nervous as can be
right he's never auditioned for anything
and
he's got his head shots and he's he's he
knows his lines he's ready to go and
suddenly he has this like rumble on the
stomach of like you know and that like
tastes in your mouth and the sweat of
like tasting well i don't know just like
the dried taste in your mouth okay like
a dry mouth situation that you're both
the watery the watery yeah that's
usually vodka yeah that's not where this
is all right sorry well this is coming
out the other end
so he realizes he he's gonna have
diarrhea like he's like there's no way
i'm not having diarrhea and it's vomit
of the animals it's coming really bad
and yeah it's coming
yeah so he goes to the bathroom but just
before he gets to there uh someone some
actor actress goes in and they lock the
door and he's he's waiting he's waiting
and he can kind of hear the person in
there like rehearsing their lines and
they're taking forever
and he like taps on the door but they're
not coming out and then he's like i'm
not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it
so he goes in the alleyway behind the
casting office
and he's like a dumpster there and he
he doesn't quite make it he he has diary
in his pants he pulls his pants down
and he's like oh my god this is a mess
this is amazing
he's trying to salvage the situation he
has no toilet paper so he's wiping his
butt with his own head shots
and the sides and the side yeah pieces
of paper and photographs of himself he's
wiping his ass with pictures of himself
there's never been a greater metaphor
for hollywood
i mean just like
it's something out of like you know like
a ben stiller absolutely
straight out of a yeah and so
as the story goes he realizes
i'm done there's there's no i can't do
the audition i got to go home
and
he gets in his car and his pants are so
ruined and they're smelling the car
smell so bad that he like takes them off
and like i don't know if he throws them
out the window whatever but he's driving
home and no pants on and as he's driving
home with no pants on he gets rear-ended
oh my god
he gets rear-ended now the rest is kind
of hazing for me like i remember there's
like a homeless guy who looks in the
window and starts yelling like that
dude's got no pants on and anyway so we
heard the story and then i think we had
it he auditioned again he because we
didn't just like automatically give him
a part we had to make sure he could i
think yeah i know he auditioned for that
he did but we we found out about it
after he had auditioned that's right so
we probably would have just given it to
him anyway because of that but then he
redforton was great and we were like yes
you hit you have earned this role
for this theme of st patrick's day i
wrote you guys some toasts which we can
do with this shot
in the style of a limerick
oh so you wrote these i wrote these
limericks for each of you but i think
that you shouldn't read the one that's
about you should read one that's about
megan this is really good megan you're a
delightful writer she's the best
who's going first who's going first i'll
go first okay because i i i don't expect
my ability to continue to speak
coherently
let's raise our glasses to glenn
the best of the five-star men
he's the host of this show can't stay
safe on the snow
and he dreams
of not chewing again
that's very so good that's very very
good yeah a lot of references and if
somebody at home doesn't think that it's
good they're [ __ ] idiots
it's very good cheers cheers we'll go a
little bit for this one please
did i already drink mine you said you
didn't want it
i don't remember rob read yours
three cheers for our pal
charlie day yeah he's one of a kind
in a way
we'd flatter him more
but he'll walk out the door
and forget every word that we said
so good it's like god damn that's good
why did i forget something
that is good
well rob that means this one's about you
i guess so
you want to hear it
yes
what are you
out anticipating the three of us yeah
i'm the one that's closest to megan oh
so you're anticipating a roast
i think it's going to be
roast devastating yeah roasty yes
but we have
we're very close so she also loves you
oh yeah we love each other very much
it's a love hate relationship as it
often is yes but she does i'm i'm
guessing she doesn't love you she likes
you but she doesn't know you that well
not not i mean right now i love
everybody yeah yeah
yeah the beauty of the whiskey but
you're keeping her
because of your sociopathy you're
keeping her that's not sociopathy that's
not certain that's not sociopathy that's
growing up in an air force family where
you moved around a lot and had to
protect yourself god that's a whole
thing okay all right that's the whole
thing that we can get into that but i
hold everyone at arm's length got it
okay and i don't like that about myself
i
it's ingrained okay uh a toast
to our good buddy rob he's the reason we
all got this job
thank god he made sonny to prove that
he's funny
cause little rose a big rose because his
other show
makes people sob
[Music]
hey rob guess who's stepping in to help
megan now
bud light seltzer are really excited for
summer because the summer comes bbq's
and get togethers and general excuses to
be outside day drinking responsibly and
nothing's gonna hit the spot quite like
bud light seltzer now what is it that
sets bud light seltzer apart from uh the
20 million other seltzers these days
well you know probably its taste and its
extensive flavor list now i want
something loud you know something uh
practically crying out for attention i'm
looking for a loudness in my bed well
loud flavors are exactly what bud light
seltzer is all about in fact the louder
the better we always say that on sunny
just get as loud as you can the louder
the better the better but let's be the
judge of that let's take a look at this
list here let's let's take a look at
this list what do they got cherry cola
bud light seltzer hard soda cherry cola
has the perfect cherry to cola seltzer
ratio for indulgent taste without all
the sugar
citrus soda the familiar lemon lime soda
flavor you secretly crave with the
seltzer stats we know you want we know
you why i like that charlie's trying to
recreate the sound of being loud because
he doesn't want to wake up anybody at
his house but he can't actually be loud
but i can twist it berry lemon cherry
and blueberry goodbye for the perfect
fruit mix refreshingly sweet to inspire
more fun
we have a new flavor alert here new
flavor alert watermelon watermelon a new
spin on a fan favorite now this seltzer
features a refreshing and sweet taste
with uh a candied watermelon aroma
[Music]
well um i wasn't as loud as as i could
have been no but i appreciate you i
appreciated the transition from from
voice to voice and you brought a lot of
um flavor you made a lot of choices in
there and i i i think you won
anyway to find a retailer who delivers
right to your door head over to
budlight.com to learn more bud light
seltzer the loudest flavors ever enjoy
responsibility messaging for 21 plus
guys you got to be 21 to drink these and
please drink responsibly don't drink
like a jerk rob did you work out this
morning no i
i i had some some crazy dreams i was up
all night from about two to about 4 30
and then i fell back asleep what were
you dreaming about back asleep
were you dreaming about it it was it was
it was dark stuff um dark stuff not for
this podcast were you dreaming you had
coven
no did you kill did you kill anybody did
you kill me
no i have a recurring nightmare that's
in that space not you
but where you kill you've murdered yeah
it's happened in the past
[Music]
but there's no reviving with it is that
i think is that like imposter syndrome
there's a fear of that you're gonna lose
it all right like if you're gonna be
arrested you're gonna lose it all so
probably in your life you know you've
accomplished these things you have this
wonderful family that's what you did you
you murdered your career and you have
this this great career and you have this
underlying fear well i'm just you know
who am i i'm not a writer i'm not an
actor i'm just i'm just rob so like i'm
a big phony and it could all be taken
away from me i am here as your friend to
tell you that that is true
um yeah and and the sooner you accept
that and just let it go and be like yeah
i'm a big fraud but so is everyone else
just ask steven steven doesn't know what
he's doing steven just each movie is
potential disaster stephen
who just stepped in the room yeah what's
up guys
what what what are we talking about well
rob has imposter syndrome and i say
don't fight it and say oh i'm a great
creator that's [ __ ] be like yeah i'm
a fraud so what so everyone's a fraud
make it till you make it baby
nobody's nobody is what they are until
they do what they do and then once you
do it then you are what you are whether
you are or aren't
but
you know basically what i'm saying is
that nobody like you said nobody really
knows what they're doing so you just
have to do it
you just have to do it yeah yeah that's
the thing and you got to be decisive
you'll get that's the thing that you run
into a lot of times with the directors
where it doesn't work you should you
you got to be decisive
to be decisive whether you're right or
wrong doesn't matter you have to right
because you're going to get down to set
the shark's not going to work and then
you got to make choices right yeah yeah
you know like you could be planning on
seeing that shark a lot suddenly you're
like you know what we're gonna have to
make this where you don't see the shark
a lot and then that's a lucky thing
because then suddenly you're like this
movie's better cause i'm not seeing the
shark as much as i'm supposed to see in
the first place so shut up about your
dreams rob
i'm in the international arrivals
terminal so everybody's here it's
actually the one they shot um love
actually in
um so the the you guys probably never
seen love actually but um women will
know that uh this is the terminal they
shot the arrivals seen in
love
the three of us shook our heads
i mean they may as well have titled that
movie men don't bother
you know and they didn't
they didn't
apparently
uh love actually
sarcastic with me movie title
[ __ ] you
yeah um it's love
uh actually it's love
yeah so
all right okay so there you go
um the answer is what is that what does
that mean was was the question posed
um
are you with me for the sex
or are you with me for something else
sweetie um are you with me for my money
uh love
actually
yeah yeah let's let's let's let's let's
talk about a movie that we've never seen
actually and pontificate on why the
movie is called why the title i like
that game yeah okay i think it could
also be um that it's like you thought
you were in love with somebody
but then you meet somebody else and
you're like
actually that's love i didn't realize
that until i met this person
this is love actually the thing before
was that most likely i thought it was
that's did i get too real did i did i
did i'd not be funny and i actually
nailed it meg did i nail it does that
mean it's like someone who's incapable
of feeling love and then
suddenly like starts to feel it and like
this is actually
this is a lot of actual love
it's actually that
yeah what if what if the movie is about
a guy named phil actually
phil actually and right and then there's
a there's star cross lovers there's a
woman named jane and she falls she falls
in love
actually jane love falls in love with
phil actually
and this is great this is really good
stuff all right so we've got to see
who's in that who's in that movie who's
in that movie everyone right isn't it
one of those
lots like 500 dollars in that movie yeah
because it's like six different stories
i i prefer your version of it to the
actual one so i'm not going to tell you
guys what happens in it because
you should break your own version yeah i
probably did see it and just don't
remember seeing it it sounds like a hugh
grant movie was he in that is it a hugh
grant joint yes hugh grant was in it oh
he
was
of course he was what are you kidding he
was
he was in love actually i believe he
played the prime minister
in the movie of love
the prime minister ladies and gentlemen
the prime minister of love
love actually
um
oh it's a christmas movie it's a
christmas movie it's a christmas movie
the prime minister of kindness of love
actually
that's the first line
right
listen to this cast for one second
hugh grant liam neeson colin firth laura
linney emma thompson alan rickman kyra
knightley martine mccutcheon don't know
bill nye rowan atkinson i must see this
movie these are fantastic actors we're
missing out yeah i mean you know it
doesn't tickle my fancy i saw the poster
i know all those people are interested i
still think they'll see they're all
great they're great actors hey they're
great they just need to do them now if
the movie was called
guns actually i probably would have gone
to see you know what i mean or like
you know fists fists actually you know
i'd be like [ __ ] yeah man what is that
like what is that [ __ ] like yeah or fist
action lee and it's about a guy named
lee in his fist action
yeah yeah and all this is faster
for sure
as a fan of glenn i recognize i can see
in his camera that he's staying in a
hotel room there's a part of me that
wants to know how many times today or
since you got to the hotel room have you
masturbated i want to know now i want to
know that as your friend i want to know
that as a fan of yours because i find it
funny i'm picturing you
landing and being like i haven't been
away from my family in like a year and a
half i'm gonna lock this door and i'm
gonna beat my dick like it owes me money
and i'm gonna do it for like a like a
solid three hours yeah i like to drink a
couple i'm gonna strip at least three or
four layers of skin off this thing
yeah you know what i mean like there's
gonna be people banging on his hotel
wall being like are you okay in there is
everything okay
i hear a lot of screaming
are you okay
there's so much screaming
voices is it how many people are in
there it's just one yeah it's just one
i'm an actor don't worry about it it's
fine i i play all the characters i'm
getting into character it's like an
eddie murphy thing every time i
masturbate all right just
just getting my character leave me alone
don't talk right now not now don't talk
to me now
um so i can understand
the the desire from
uh a person out there in the world like
i wouldn't i think that would be amazing
if i'm listening to
uh smartlist and i and and and jason
were to check himself into a hotel room
and he started would start talking about
that i would find it absolutely
fascinating and probably hilarious but
there's also a weird connection because
anybody that's alone or have been alone
or away from people for the first time
in a long time knows exactly what that
feeling is like but we don't talk about
it a lot in public because it's either
base or private or whatever
i get that too and i also understand why
you wouldn't want to tweet that out to
the world
but yet i still mean that's here
yeah sure i mean that's why you built a
whole separate little house for yourself
right so that you could just have it
right that's yeah you call it tell me
why you were so sweaty and 18 minutes
late
yes
look this was not for sweat oh no
the listener
i think megan almost threw up
yeah there's been look look i spend a
lot of time down here
i'm i'm a human being
yeah of course from time to time i find
me time for myself
your needs and a high speed internet
connection and
that leads to another and
[Laughter]
i wonder what percentage of our audience
just
masturbates to the podcast
you know there's probably like like one
one person right at least
should we give somebody should we give
them something should we should we take
our shirts off do you guys remember that
cable
show in new york new york one like
where it was like news during the day
yeah and at night it was robin bird
robin we talked about this cinema on the
podcast i don't think so i don't think
we talked about robin bird um so it was
like soft core porn yeah yeah like well
it was
yeah i i was like of like naked she
would have like streams she would have
slashed men yeah it was it was both
women and men and they would be well
there was men for men it was meant for
men and then women from for government
and then they would come and they would
basically be all for men it was all for
matters
[Laughter]
yeah there would there wouldn't be any
like fornication no but they would
destroy but they would strip naked and
then they then they would plug what
strip club they were working at in the
city there was like a weird song on the
robin bird show too it was like right uh
baby let me bang your box
baby let me bang your box
but she was singing it she was singing
she was about well she's singing it
about herself and saying that she's been
banging since she was a little girl
since she was a little kid
see that kind of that's upsetting there
was a dark but there was a well darkness
okay wait let me play the let me play
devil's advocate for a second okay is
there also something to like you know
how that somebody is
scantily clad it's more attractive than
someone who's just like completely naked
do you see do you do you feel that way
wait say that again meaning like
when there's a little air of mystery
where you're like i can see
aspects of your nudity and your body
through your clothing for example
is maybe more attractive than someone
who's just like nude yes i i agree with
that yeah i like a little mystery yeah
meg like when you see a juicy dong
hanging down somebody's pant leg is that
better than seeing the dong itself yeah
i don't want to see any more than half
of it right yeah sure but you don't mind
seeing the top
yeah a little bush
well glenn we've established that you
are the host of the show could you what
should we do next um well i so so here
this is a little awkward or maybe it
isn't i don't know i always write notes
on my phone when i watch the episode
right like if i have questions i want to
ask you guys or things i want to talk
about or whatever
it looks like i'm just looking at my
phone in the in the video but
you know just know
uh listener watcher
you [ __ ] creep
uh that when i'm looking at my phone
that's great it's insulting
the audience apparently half the
audience watches the podcast okay and
you've just called them all creeps a lot
of people watch and i like that glenn
calls them creeps and i think we should
just call them the creeps well when you
call someone a watcher it just sounds
creepy i'm not saying they're creeps i'm
just saying when you call someone a
watcher it sounds great
like call someone a listener it's like
yeah listener right but i i think maybe
that's kind of fun that if the the
audience on the uh who's listening to
this in on the drive
to and fro work um they're the listener
and anybody who's watching is a creep
by the way
we did it this is great we definitely
did it we did the [ __ ] out of it yeah
and um
good luck editing this
jesus christ
god bless play us out charlie okay
have something
that's a lot of pressure
we came
to be funny
but we searched for the truth
we
told some yarns
got along in the tooth
but life's just that way
if you're lucky that is
i guess i'm just
foolish
for living in bliss
for i
am happy
i guess that makes me
awfully sunny
and that's why
we're here
[Music]
for we
are sunny
even though we
seem blake
sometimes it may appear
[Music]
but we
are
sunny
cause we're hopeful
[Music]
in a way
and we're honest
with each other
[Music]
and i guess that's
just the way
[Music]
we appear
[Music]
we are sunny
in our way
and this will be
what we're known for
[Music]
till our very
last day
oh my god
that's good man
very good
i don't know i just got actually
emotional
that's the whiskey
let's keep talking
wow that just that just really got me
yeah that's what it's like
huh that's what it's like being with him
you know
i don't know i said
you